[Music]  once upon a time there was a great war  the book so much sadness to so many  people hardly anyone could remember what  happiness was light but something  happened that changed all that  [Music]  his name is Christopher Robin but we  generally called him Billy  a taste see our milk yeah it helped us  to believe in the good things that one  would like that's what I know so  hopefully okay the fun thing he's your  favorite  I have to go for the little one collect  firstly piglet and a world full of  imagination  you  [Music]  all these white turnip it I thought  we're just having fun we're writing a  book and we're having fun and then just  like if haply turned on happiness  Kim puling act  [Music]  you